Ron you're not wearing shoulder pads are
you that was the rumor oh my god
lips and shoulder pads now someone says
you wearing shoulder pads oh so you
don't have shoulder pads no you thought
you didn't feel like it was Jason Jason
has issues I guess you know cuz he can't
wear any clothes he was a he was a
[ __ ] tank borg everyday mumu why are
you spreading rumors about rude
yesterday Ronnie had about yeah had
about three extra inches on his shoulder
I did not to destroy I know what is sold
have had in the suit feels like it's
where necessary josh is so worried about
what I wear about what you [ __ ]
sweatshirt every day so go tell Howard
about it what do you got for me you were
sold yesterday
no JD go double-check and he did he put
his hands over huge D make a suit they
put pads in there to make a jacket look
I know about heads but your pad was like
six inches were the same sooner I will
sleep super Monday okay I touched this
suit is not watching me to CBS shoulder
pads on nothing today's the same suit
let me ask you something though because
Ronnie where's his shirt unbuttoned now
and there's always a little t-shirt
under that's right that's his new what
is that look is that it's my new change
for right now okay it's his new k your
clothes we made me a bit of his mock
turtleneck and today the t-shirt is
matching the shirt at all it looks all
it's Ronnie's way of saying okay I have
to wear a suit to work but I'm edgy it's
his Miami Vice look you know it's like
hey I'm not gonna wear a tie I don't I'm
a rebel even though I have to wear a
suit I like it hey Ron could I be honest
with what the rumor I heard and be
honest dancing are you plucking your
eyebrows no come on you know
trying to groom a little bit you know
look at the close-up that's terrible
he's a job okay I tried to be doing a
terrible job you know I said I did it
[ __ ] job okay cuz it looks like you
should eyebrows look like an accident
it was an accident I went too far
how do you trim them with one of those
bows of things but why you trimming your
eyebrows I don't do that because I got a
little fuzzy you know yeah look at look
at the close-up on that seriously you're
close to just shaving them off and then
drawing in your eye
no I'm not gonna do that dude I made a
mistake do it seriously for God's sakes
what are those new glasses those are
very expensive Bulgari a glasses right
I've been wearing these for over a year
already where have you been no those are
expensive gallery yeah Bulgari
there were 500 bucks Wow my roller good
for you but look at those eyebrows do
Robin do you see that I see that's a
mess he shaved his eyebrows I can't
believe what I'm seeing
yeah shame I just told you that how
often do you shave your eyebrows I don't
shave them yeah what do whatever it is
that was a criminal I don't say two
calendar days are those trimmers though
the kind of thing that leaves the five
o'clock shadow it's probably yeah wrong
truck
no what happened when it closed exactly
think there's a setting thing on it you
know I used the wrong setting okay all
right Thank You Ryan
it's weird I can't believe Ronnie